[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous
quand vous avez lu mon nom et mon titre
sur le programme Julie Narbé directrice
générale du Centre Pompidou vous vous
êtes sûrement dit tiens elle fait partie
du milieu de l'art et d'une certaine
manière vous avez pas complètement tort
Centre Pompidou milieu de l'art
intéressant ce rapport au Cercle dès le
début
qu'est-ce que ça évoque pour vous le
milieu de l'art et plus particulièrement
le milieu de l'art contemporain
j'imagine que pour la plupart d'entre
vous le milieu de l'art c'est un cercle
très fermé
élitiste qui cultive un certain entre
soi on va voir des expositions on va
dans des galeries d'art on va au
vernissage
on se précipite de chaque automne à la
FIAC alors attention pour les initiés ça
ne s'appelle plus la FIAC ça s'appelle
Paris plus
retenez-le pour l'automne prochain
je suis sûr que chacun d'entre vous dans
la salle a fait l'expérience dans sa vie
de se retrouver face à une œuvre d'art
et de penser tout bas autour
je ne comprends rien
ou alors
ça ne sert vraiment à rien
ou pire mais ce soir on va rester poli
je vais vous faire un aveu
moi aussi ça m'arrive encore
mais comment ça m'arrive à chaque fois
au fond de moi il y a une petite voix
qui me dit
et cette comprendre
fait confiance à l'artiste ça c'était un
conseil de mon président au Palais de
Tokyo fait confiance à l'artiste c'était
très précieux
et c'est de comprendre ce que l'artiste
a voulu nous dire sur le monde et cette
question elle est fondamentale qu'est-ce
que l'artiste a voulu nous dire sur le
monde
elle est fondamentale parce que
l'artiste c'est l'anti algorithme
quand vous regardez une exposition une
oeuvre un spectacle ce qui se passe
c'est l'exact inverse de ce qui se passe
quand vous êtes sur les réseaux sociaux
ou sur les plateformes de contenu en
ligne quand vous allez sur TikTok sur
Instagram sur Netflix on vous dit vous
avez regardé ça alors lisez ça
ou alors vous avez likez ça
alors regardez ça
vous tombez dans le cercle infernal
c'est confortable
et oui c'est confortable parce que
vous êtes conforté dans vos idées dans
vos goûts vous pouvez les partager avec
votre communauté
mais vous ne sortez plus du cercle et au
fond
c'est votre liberté de penser qui est de
plus en plus réduite
l'artiste lui il ne pense pas comme vous
et moi
j'aime bien dire qu'il est une sorte
d'anthropologue du contemporain par son
regard différent il va vous faire voir
le monde différemment c'est comme s'il
cherchait à révéler
une autre réalité et c'est ça qui est
passionnant
c'est se confronter à ce regard
différent des artistes qui vous permet
d'élargir le cercle d'exercer votre
libre arbitre de penser plus librement
alors je vais vous raconter peut-être
une expérience qui est peut-être la plus
marquante
de mon rapport à l'art c'était en 2016
au Palais de Tokyo on avait invité un
artiste qui s'appelle Tino Segal
Tino Segal c'est un artiste qui est pas
comme les autres parce qu'il ne fait pas
d'oeuvre matérielles toutes ces œuvres
ne sont constituées que de rencontres
humaines de sorte de performance ce
qu'il appelle des situations construites
alors je m'apprête à entrer dans
l'espace d'exposition
et là un enfant vient me prendre la main
il me regarde
et il me dit qu'est-ce que le progrès
alors j'improvise quelques mots
un petit peu gêné s'engage une
conversation et puis on continue à
marcher et un adolescent vient prendre
le relais de l'enfant continue cette
conversation on marche on marche puis un
adulte vient finir cette conversation au
total
donc cette expérience cette œuvre
dure environ 5 minutes
j'étais pas très à l'aise à la fin
j'étais pas très contente de moi parce
que je dois vous avouer que je crois que
la question du progrès en 2016
elle n'était pas au centre de mes
préoccupations
mais pensez-y aujourd'hui
à l'heure des bouleversements
climatiques qui font l'actualité tous
les jours évidemment la réponse elle
serait très différente
ce serait peut-être plus pertinent
mais je repense souvent à cette
expérience parce que ce qui est
intéressant c'est que l'artiste cette
question il me l'a posé il y a presque
10 ans
et elle était puissante cette question
dans mon quotidien
j'ai la chance d'être confronté
presque tous les jours peut-être pas
tout à fait à cette vision que les
artistes nous offrent du monde que ce
soit les artistes modernes qui sont
accrochés sur les murs de du musée au
Centre Pompidou que ce soit les artistes
contemporains que je peux rencontrer que
ce soit des danseurs des écrivains des
architectes ou des créateurs en général
et ce qui me fait lever le matin
ça n'est pas le énième cocktail du soir
ça croyez-moi on s'enlace très très vite
mais c'est l'idée de faire grandir cette
liberté
de la partager avec le plus grand nombre
aux autres Pompidou tous les jours on
accueille des classes
on se déplace dans les écoles on
travaille avec des associations pour
aller à la rencontre des publics qui ne
vont pas au musée qui n'ont pas accès à
l'art
on a créé un programme qui s'appelle un
jour une heure
on prend une oeuvre originale de notre
collection on la met dans un petit
camion et on l'amène
on a fait ça à Massy on l'amène dans un
lieu où la reine ne va jamais ou va peu
un hôpital pour enfants un centre de
migrants un supermarché une piscine
municipale
on a même créé un camion qui s'appelle
le mémo le musée mobile en lien avec une
association et qui permet
d'emmener une petite exposition dans le
camion de ville en ville de village en
village de banlieue en banlieue à la
rencontre de ces publics qui sont pas
familiers avec la
et à chaque fois ce que je me dis c'est
qu'on plante des petites graines dans
chacun de ces visiteurs pour faire
grandir leur liberté et pour faire des
petits pas pour la démocratie
vous l'aurez compris ce qui m'anime
c'est deux choses
la première
c'est protéger la liberté de création
l'affaire grandir soutenir les artistes
et le regard qui nous apporte sur le
monde
et croyez-moi cette liberté de création
même en France elle est fragile et
parfois elle est remise en question
et la deuxième chose qui m'anime c'est
de partager avec le plus grand nombre
ces créations cette liberté pour que
l'art soit partout et partager
laissez-moi vous raconter une dernière
histoire qui nous m'est arrivé il y a
quelques temps c'était il y a un mois au
Centre Pompidou
on avait invité un artiste
nigérian
à faire une performance rencontre
spectacle c'était intéressant d'ailleurs
on savait pas tellement comment
qualifier cet événement il s'appelle
Kudos onikaku c'est un danseur et
chorégraphe de hip-hop
je me dis tiens je vais emmener ma fille
de 12 ans qui fait du hip-hop ça va
peut-être lui plaire
sur le chemin
j'exerce moi-même ma propre liberté en
me disant je suis épuisée j'ai une
journée
très dure si c'est pas bien je partirai
discrètement
on arrive
l'artiste était là au milieu de la pièce
avec ses musiciens il y avait une
chanteuse inuite un percussionniste
indien un guitariste
et il nous invite à nous mettre en
cercle encore un cercle
en ce qui est amusant c'est qu'on
s'approche et spontanément les gens se
mettent pieds nus comme lui c'est quand
même pas courant dans un musée on se met
tous pieds nus
en cercle autour de l'artiste il nous
accueille il nous explique qu'il est
très heureux d'être avec nous que rien
que le fait qu'on se rencontre ce soir
l'intérêt qu'on va chanter danser
écouter de la musique
on se laisse emporter par cet artiste il
nous invite à danser la musique est
forte elle est assez lancinante comme
des rythmes chamaniques on a passé
presque deux heures
complètement hors du temps dans cette
expérience à nul autre pareil
emporté par cet artiste si charismatique
et à la fin
ma fille me regarde me dit
maman on peut revenir demain
merci à tous
[Applaudissements]